[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 9 novembre voici le
programme après octobre rose c'est au
tour du Movember le mois de
sensibilisation au cancer masculin en
novembre les hommes sont notamment
invités à faire un dépistage du cancer
de la prostate cette maladie touche un
homme sur 8 c'est messieurs sont
d'ailleurs conviés à se laisser pousser
la moustache pour soutenir la cause nous
en parlerons avec notre invité Freddy
payer ambassadeur du mouvement
aujourd'hui l'Institut d'études de
politiques de Saint-Germain les plus
connus sous le nom de Sciences Po
Saint-Germain assigné un partenariat
avec la Direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire c'est en lien avec
l'enquête qui sera menée par les
étudiants sur l'état des lieux de
l'enseignement en milieu pénitentiaire
nous retrouverons notre journaliste sur
place Nicolas dandry pour faire le point
sur cette collaboration le mercredi
c'est le jour de notre page cinéma nous
parlerons des films à ne pas manquer
dans les prochains jours Black Panther 2
Armageddon time ou encore pétaouchnock
ce sera avec notre journaliste Céline
Charles au programme également le coup
de cœur d'une réalisatrice et la
web-série au KLM filmé par des
collégiens à Rambouillet avec Benjamin
palier et avec moi en plateau Mickael el
midoro bonsoir vous allez nous parler de
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines effectivement et on va parler
notamment du départ de la Route du Rhum
avec Eric Bellion et Louis Burton qui
ont pris le départ c'était à 14h15
précise aujourd'hui au large de la
Bretagne
aussi également avec Céline Charles une
autre journaliste de la rédaction de TV
78 vous allez nous parler des sorties
cinéma d'aujourd'hui ou bien un grand
programme encore dans les salles
obscures cette semaine comme vous l'avez
dit un nouveau film signé James Grey la
suite d'un film de super-héros un drame
franco-belge et une comédie montagnarde
et ce sera donc en seconde partie
d'émission mais avant ça je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
matin dans les Yvelines le brouillard
sera bien présent sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
comptez 8 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 7 degrés à Houdan et 6 degrés
à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le
brouillard devrait se dissiper pour
laisser place à de belles éclaircies au
niveau des températures il fera 11 à 14
degrés en moyenne le point maintenant
sur l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Michael on commence
par l'information du jour ce sera la
grève de demain et oui un nouveau
mouvement social les prévu demain la
RATP prévoit un trafic fortement
perturbé pour la ligne A du RER prévoit
en moyenne intrins sur deux toute la
journée pour les branches sergy-le-haut
Poissy pour le reste de la ligne prévoir
en moyenne un train sur deux en heure de
pointe un train sur 4 en heures creuses
interconnexion est interrompue à Gare du
Nord pour la ligne B le RER C est un peu
moins touché avec trois trains sur 4 en
moyenne du côté à des Transiliens le
trafic sera quasi normal sur la ligne u
pas d'information communiquée sur les
lignes J et l et deux trains sur 3 sur
la ligne N il y aura aussi des
perturbations sur les lignes de bus en
moyenne de bus sur 3 sur le réseau RATP
le côté scolaire sera lui aussi impacté
le lycée à basse camp de Rambouillet par
exemple les agents de la région ont
décidé de se mettre en grève il proteste
contre l'insuffisance des effectifs des
postes pas trop vu et des personnels non
remplacés c'était attendu depuis
plusieurs jours mais quel la Route du
Rhum est enfin lancée ils ont enfin
appris la mer les 138 à skippers de la
Route du Rhum sont partis en début
d'après-midi de Saint-Malo direction la
Guadeloupe le départ de données devait
être donné le dimanche 6 novembre
dernier mais les conditions météo en ont
décidé autrement au sein de la course de
yvinois Laurent bolitain à Louis Burton
et le versaillé Eric Bellion et on leur
souhaite bonne chance bien entendu on
continue avec du sport Michael après le
football féminin le rugby la ville de
Croissy-sur-Seine sera le camp de base
de la sélection ton GN c'est la deuxième
commune yvelinoise a accueillir une
équipe lors de cette Coupe du Monde 2023
le pays de Gal posera ses valises à
Versailles début de la compétition ce
sera le 8 septembre 2023 un dernier mot
de sport cette fois ça concerne les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 la ville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux va peut-être
accueillir les meilleurs pongistes
mondiaux le centre sportif les pyramides
a été retenu comme le titre de
préparation pour les JO et les
paralympiques de 2024 en novembre 2021
le club skipping organisait le Skype à
RATP French Open 200 sportifs de tous
les continents c'était affrontés à noter
que les épreuves se dérouleront dans la
future Arena par issue 4 et le chiffre
du jour Michael c'est 200 pourquoi 200
c'est le nombre de bénévoles dont a
besoin le Secours populaire à dés
Yvelines l'association qui vient en aide
à des bénéficiaires toujours plus
nombreux à besoin de petites mains et de
grandes volonté pour l'opération paquet
cadeau mais aussi pour les collectes
alimentaires pour s'inscrire direction
le site secours
populaire.fr/78 et on termine avec une
information internationale qui touche
quelques-uns de nos habitants yvelinois
certains imminences côté les résultats
avec attention pour un vote de mi-mandat
les mi-temps aux États-Unis les citoyens
américains étaient appelés aux urnes
pour renouveler une grande partie de
leur représentant au Congrès leur est
encore au dépouillement mais les
républicains disposent du net longueur
d'avance avec 200 sièges contre 74 pour
les démocrates ça c'est pour la chambre
du côté du signal et des démocrates
obtiennent 46 sièges face à 47 pour les
républicains et deux sièges pour les
autres partis les expatriés en France
sont aussi participé à ce scrutin le
représentant du parti démocrate vit dans
les Yvelines à nous partage son
sentiment face à ses premiers résultats
la vague rouge n'a pas eu lieu le raie
de marée annoncé par les républicains
n'a pas eu lieu pour la bonne et simple
raison c'est que à part quelques
sondages de qualité ces dernières temps
les sondages poubelles financés par la
républicains donnaient tous les
républicains gagnants et ils ont cru à
leur propre mensonge
leur candidat était vraiment trop
extrême et les gens n'ont n'acceptent
pas l'extrémisme des candidats
républicains
beaucoup Mickael el midoro et bien sûr
si vous vous avez trouvé une information
vous avez vu quelque chose qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le partager sur Twitter avec le
hashtag 78 news
j'en parlais en début d'émission l'école
de Sciences Po de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
a signé cet après-midi un partenariat
avec la Direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire et nous retrouvons sur
place notre journaliste Nicolas d'André
il est avec Aurélie fillot Chabot
adjointe au laboratoire de la recherche
et de l'innovation au Ministère de la
Justice Nicolas vous m'entendez
bonsoir Mathilde effectivement je suis
avec Aurélie fille au Chambeau donc qui
travaille au ministère de la Justice
alors voilà vous venez de signer un
partenariat avec Sciences Po
Saint-Germain pour permettre aux
étudiants de faire une enquête sur
l'enseignement au milieu de pénitent
alors quel est l'intérêt pour vous de
bénéficier de cette enquête alors au
sein de l'administration pénitentiaire
on a en bénéficie déjà de beaucoup de
recherches réalisées par le milieu
universitaire mais là on avait envie de
décaler le regard et de faire réaliser
cette recherche par des étudiants de
Sciences Po Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc à
la fois décaler le regard et aussi avoir
ma justice qui qui suivent des cours et
de l'enseignement c'est un nombre
important parce que oui moi je vous
disais que c'était finalement la
jeunesse qui était plus concernée et
puis finalement non c'est une part
importante quand même les majeurs
en détention on a très très peu de
mineurs fort heureusement la plupart des
personnes qui sont en détention sont des
hommes majeurs et on a à peu près 30% de
cette population qui suit des cours très
régulièrement vous l'avez dit un regard
de la jeunesse des étudiants de Sciences
Po de Saint-Germain-en-Laye alors des
deuxième année mais il y a d'autres
aussi étudiants qui vont participer à
cette enquête pourquoi ça apporte
quelque chose de d'innovant de quelque
chose de nouveau qu'est-ce qui est
intéressant d'avoir un regard de jeunes
comme ça
alors à la fois effectivement vous avez
pas vous avez parlé du mot innovant pour
nous c'est assez innovant de de de
permettre à la jeunesse de d'aller en
détention et de travailler sur ces
questions là c'est aussi une manière
pour nous de sensibiliser les jeunes à
des enjeux des questions sociétales qui
sont pas forcément qui vont pas
forcément de soi pour quand on fait ses
études et donc ça peut être créer des
vocations et permettre à ces étudiants
aussi d'aller travailler dans les
métiers de la justice et plus
particulièrement dans les métiers de
l'Administration Pénitentiaire merci
Aurélie fille au Chambaud d'être resté
avec nous la signature a eu lieu il y a
déjà un peu moins d'une heure merci
d'être resté avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes adjointe au sein du
laboratoire rechercher innovation du de
la direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire au sein du ministère de la
Justice et donc Mathilde j'ai d'autres
invités qui vont me rejoindre ils vont
me rejoindre donc
je crois que vous êtes avec Céline
braconnier du coup la directrice de
Sciences Po Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
également une étudiante qui va mener du
coup l'enquête dont vous parlez à
l'instant Farah Didouche
effectivement Mathilde braconnier qui
est juste à côté de moi et Farid douche
juste à côté donc il est étudiante à
Sciences Po alors déjà c'est une
braconnier qu'est-ce que ça représente
pour vous ce type de partenariat avec
quand même un ministère important un
ministère régalien le ministère de la
Justice d'abord le ministère la justice
est un partenaire de Sciences Po parce
qu'on prépare nos étudiants au métier de
la justice par le biais de prêt PAS
concours par le biais de de Master qui
qui sont consacrés à
ces questions là mais c'est aussi un
partenaire de la recherche depuis
l'ouverture de Sciences Po on a un
laboratoire de recherche qui s'appelle
le 16 deep dont les ministères de la
Justice et tutelle donc on a des
chercheurs confirmés qui travaillent sur
ces questions en lien avec le ministère
de justice et puis on a nos jeunes
étudiants qu'on essaye voilà de d'ouvrir
aux questions de recherche liées au
monde judiciaire et notamment cette
fois-ci au monde carcéral pour créer une
appétence et un intérêt donc tout le
monde a tout le monde a gagné nous on se
sert finalement de ces demandes sociales
de compréhension de ce qui se passe en
prison pour former aussi des jeunes aux
méthodes des sciences sales et aux
enquêtes de deux terrains dans des
situations un peu particulières alors le
travail a déjà commencé vous avez
notamment présenté une vidéo où on voit
les étudiants qui sont déjà au travail
depuis le mois de septembre alors pas
comment ça se passe depuis le mois de
septembre par rapport à ce projet
alors depuis le mois de septembre du
coup on a pu découvrir le milieu
carcéral et pouvoir véritablement s'en
imprégner on a tout d'abord fait des
lectures scientifiques dans un premier
temps et aussi on a pu rencontrer
différents acteurs qui connaissent
véritablement ce milieu ce qui est assez
rare donc c'est vraiment une chance pour
nous on a rencontré des responsables
associés des responsables de
l'enseignement dans le milieu
pénitentiaire et aussi bientôt on va
rencontrer des prisonniers pour le
moment on est encore dans la préparation
des entretiens avec les prisonniers qui
va bientôt arriver le 24 novembre c'est
ça l'enquête de terrain comme on dit ça
va commencer le 24 novembre le premier
terrain aura lieu le 24 novembre et ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant c'est que on va
initier les étudiants à faire à la fois
des entretiens des entretiens de groupe
avec des détenus bénéficiants d'une
formation en prison avec aussi des
enseignants pour pouvoir croiser les
perceptions de l'enseignement tel qu'il
se déroule aujourd'hui dans ces lieux de
prévention et puis on va aussi initier
les étudiants à faire des observations
en classe donc tout ça cette approche un
peu à partir de plusieurs méthodes et
très intéressantes pour eux et puis très
intéressant pour nous aussi parce que ce
sont des questions qui sont très peu
encore investis par la recherche de
façon générale les prisons sont assez
peu voilà investis mais cette question
de l'enseignement en prison les
particulièrement et l'intérêt pour les
étudiants c'est aussi d'être associé à
la préparation d'un renouvellement d'une
politique publique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
savent que les données scientifiques ils
vont produire les analyses qui vont
produire à partir de ces données
serviront pourront servir à repenser
l'enseignement en prison dans les années
à venir et ça c'est très stimulant pour
des jeunes étudiants voilà qui sont en
premier cycle encore une fois ils sont
très jeunes quand vous entendez ces
libraconniers justement dire que vous
allez peut-être contribuer à des
modifications des ajustements de
politique publique alors là dans le
cadre de l'enseignement de la dans la
détention qu'est-ce que ça représente
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous de
contribuer à ce ce type de produits on
est tous très contents en fait de
pouvoir participer à ce projet c'est
vraiment une grande chance pour nous
quelle est la place de ce projet d'une
telle enquête dans la pédagogie dans le
parcours des étudiants à Sciences Po
Saint-Germain alors c'est particulier
parce que en deuxième année après avoir
eu une formation un peu académique avec
beaucoup de cours magistraux en première
année en deuxième année on les initie à
d'autres formats et donc notamment ce
format de projet recherche qui s'étend
tout au long de l'année au cours duquel
voilà on a des séances de préparation
sous la forme d'atelier à des terrains
et on les emmène sur le terrain donc ça
les sort déjà de Sciences Po parce que
on les on les fait venir dans ces écoles
là ils y font des des études de façon
très sérieuse sont des étudiants très
bon très brillants très investis très
passionnés mais on les capte pas à l'IEP
pour les garder on les on les capte pour
les outils pour comprendre le monde et
puis ensuite pour agir sur lui donc là
c'est une bonne initiation à ce que peut
permettre le suivi d'études dans des
écoles comme comme la nôtre c'est-à-dire
que on nous dit on forme on accompagne
les étudiants pour leur permettre
ensuite de façon plus autonome de d'agir
d'agir sur le monde et de faire qu'il
aille mieux deux dernières questions
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous évoque
l'enseignement au milieu de détention
pour vous alors l'enseignement ça évoque
un contexte très contraignant dans
lequel évidemment les questions de
sécurité peuvent voilà croiser d'autres
ambitions les empêcher d'aboutir et donc
il s'agit de voir comment essayer
d'aménager l'enseignement de sorte que
l'ambition de réinsertion qu'on vise à
travers cette question de l'enseignement
en détention soit pleinement investis et
pouvoir davantage accompagner les
enseignants les besoins qu'ils expriment
depuis pas mal de temps il y a un besoin
très clairement d'introduire le
numérique les ordinateurs en détention
notamment pour améliorer l'enseignement
donc ça ce sont des questions qu'on va
investir voilà à partir du 23 novembre
sur et dernière question du coup où se
feront ces observations je ne veux pas
le dire on va voilà on va avoir des des
établissements en région parisienne et
d'autres hors régions parisiennes pour
l'instant on n'a pas on n'est pas
autorisé à donner le nom des
établissements vous êtes prêtes à aller
sur le terrain ça y est bientôt ici oui
parfait merci Céline braconnier donc
directrice de Sciences Po Saint-Germain
et Farah Didouche qui est donc étudiante
dans l'établissement et voilà Mathilde
je pense qu'on va suivre cette enquête
menée par Sciences Po Saint-Germain on
va les suivre notamment les résultats
dans les mois qui viennent les premiers
résultats de cette enquête sur
l'enseignement en détention et Merci à
VOUS Nicolas dandry d'avoir réalisé ces
interviews en direct on en parlait en
début d'émission le Movember ce mois
pour sensibiliser au cancer masculin
Freddy Payard vous êtes connecté avec
nous à distance bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde vous êtes ambassadeur
de ce mouvement qui existe depuis 2023
un certain nombre d'années quel est son
impact aujourd'hui est-ce que il y a de
plus en plus de dépistage grâce à ce
mouvement
donc en fait le mouvement il a été créé
en 2003 en Australie
et donc il est arrivé en France en 2011
2012 donc c'est assez récent on connaît
beaucoup octobre rose pour les femmes
les cancers féminins en octobre on
connaît beaucoup le Téléthon et entre
les deux il y a le mois de novembre qui
est dédié aux maladies masculines donc
en fait Movember c'est une communauté de
Rockstar qui récolte des fonds qui se
mobilisent pour faire bouger des choses
en termes de santé mentale prévention du
suicide et dans la lutte contre les
cancers de la prostate et des testicules
donc l'idée avec la moustache c'est de
faire prendre conscience aux personnes
d'aller se faire dépister et parce que
c'est encore des sujets qui sont tabous
chez les hommes est-ce que vous voyez
une évolution est-ce que grâce à ce
mouvement Movember et justement au fait
que plus en plus d'hommes portent la
moustache pour pour soutenir la cause
est-ce que vous voyez une évolution des
dépistages
alors moi en termes de chiffres j'ai pas
de chiffres forcément à donner mais
c'est vrai que l'idée de la moustache ça
se voit c'est en plein milieu de la
figure et l'idée c'est de faire prendre
conscience aux personnes d'aller se
faire dépister d'aller se faire tester
c'est le premier concert chez les hommes
le cancer de la prostate donc à partir
de 50 ans il est conseillé d'aller se
faire dépister d'aller voir son médecin
pour faire un contrôle de routine
l'idée de mauvais beurre c'est vraiment
sensible et les personnes à être
sensible à tous ces sujets là et comment
ça se passe justement le dépistage
comment on fait pour se faire dépister
donc en fait c'est un rendez-vous chez
le médecin et du coup c'est il y a
différentes techniques et des techniques
qui ont été mises au point justement par
les financements de mauvais beurre des
nouvelles techniques révolutionnaires
donc tout ça ça c'est des techniques qui
évoluent
donc
après c'est vraiment un rendez-vous chez
le médecin en premier temps et après
c'est des des diagnostics plus précis
avec des examens plus précis et donc je
le disais vous êtes ambassadeur du
mouvement Movember pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé d'être ambassadeur de
ce mouvement
alors en France on est deux ambassadeurs
donc on n'est pas beaucoup c'est comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est un
mouvement qui vient d'Australie donc
c'est très connu dans les pays
anglo-saxons donc en dans l'été j'ai été
contacté par le quartier général qui est
basé à Londres c'est le quartier général
qui gère mauvaise beurre au niveau de
l'Europe et donc ils m'ont contacté cet
été j'ai participé à une réunion en
septembre à Londres et depuis je suis
officiellement ambassadeur pour la
Fondation Movember donc mon rôle
c'est de faire connaître la fondation
qui est très peu connue en France
de mettre en place des collectes de
fonds donc j'ai mis en place un défi
sportif ça fait trois ans que je propose
un défi sportif pour récolter des fonds
et j'organise aussi deux événements donc
le premier il a eu lieu à Bourgtheroulde
dimanche dernier
on a rassemblé près de 40 personnes un
peu plus de 200 euros pour la Fondation
mon Amber et le deuxième événement il
aura lieu à Saint-Marcel c'est à une
demi-heure de Mantes-la-Jolie donc ça
sera la mauvaise Cup et donc là ça sera
pareil équipe de 2 et les gens pourront
participer à différents ateliers il y
aura un classement et l'idée c'est
vraiment de s'amuser pour une bonne
cause et d'ailleurs le site Internet de
Movember tient un classement des
meilleurs ambassadeurs qui ont récolté
le plus de dons et alors j'ai fait mes
petites recherches vous êtes cinquième
au classement
j'ai regardé hier je suis top 5
actuellement après ça évolue parce que
en fonction des gens comment ils
organisent la collecte de fonds ça
évolue beaucoup actuellement je suis top
5 mais ça peut changer donc j'invite les
gens à faire un don sur mon space on
m'en trouve assez facilement c'est sur
le site de Movember et ensuite on tape
mon nom mon prénom et on me assez
facilement c'est un mouvement qui vous
touche Movember personnellement alors
j'ai découvert le mouvement quand j'ai
été professeur en Angleterre en 2017
c'est parti d'un
juste d'un défi entre collègues de prof
de sport se laisser pousser d'un
moustache et puis au fur et à mesure des
années je me suis senti beaucoup plus
impliqué parce que dans mon entourage et
j'ai des gens qui ont été concernés par
le cancer de la prostate donc des gens
qui sont partis trop tôt
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de d'être
investi le plus possible pour faire
connaître toutes les causes que défend
mauvais beurre donc c'est la prévention
des suicides
c'est la santé mentale
la santé mentale c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu qui est moins connu du grand
public
alors qu'il y a trois personnes sur 4
ils sont confrontés à des problèmes
durant l'année donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de d'en parler
de d'oser en parler en fait à d'autres
personnes et par le sport moi je suis
coach sportif je me rends bien compte
que les gens ils ont besoin de se
défouler ils ont besoin de lâcher prise
et le j'utilise l'outil du sport pour
leur permettre de se défouler et de
lâcher prise
d'être venu en parler avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes ambassadeur du
mouvement Movember et si vous souhaitez
faire un don rendez-vous sur le site
fr.ove.com qui s'affiche juste en
dessous c'est un projet qui est né lors
de l'année scolaire
2021-2022 travailler autour de la
mémoire en histoire une vingtaine
d'élèves au lycée Corneille de La
Celle-Saint-Cloud s'est penché sur cette
réflexion qui aboutit un livre et pour
cette nouvelle année le travail se
tourne du côté de la géographie nous
avons assisté à leur premier temps de
travail regardez
[Musique]
quelle trace laisse un lieu dans notre
mémoire quel souvenir déclenche-t-il
Sophie fait partie de ses élèves du
lycée Corneille de La Celle-Saint-Cloud
a participé à un travail autour des
souvenirs j'aime pas trop parler des
choses personnelles et du coup là c'est
quand même une opportunité de le faire
au lycée on s'attend pas forcément à
parler à quelque chose qui nous touche
de cyprès et du coup je trouvais ça
intéressant et puis aussi c'est vrai que
les profs ils nous ont quand même laissé
une assez grande une vingtaine d'élèves
a répondu à la proposition de plusieurs
professeurs de l'établissement récit
poème interview la mémoire se
transmettra dans différents formats j'ai
tout de suite pensé à mon site de danse
et du coup je me suis dit ce serait
formidable que moi j'arrive à faire
transmettre des émotions par rapport à
ce que j'adore faire c'est un défi oui
parce que c'est compliqué d'écrire mais
en même temps vu que j'adore le sujet et
que j'aime bien aussi écrire tout ce qui
est français tout ça les rédactions
c'est toujours quelque chose qui m'a plu
la mémoire autour de la géographie et le
deuxième volet d'un projet du lycée
Corneille en 2021-2022 les élèves
volontaires ont réfléchi à la mémoire
historique pour faire naître un livre
j'ai pu interviewer mon grand-père et du
coup ça m'a donné une occasion de
discuter avec lui et j'ai adoré je l'ai
interviewé sur la garde d'Algérie parce
qu'il a eu une expérience là-bas en tant
que soldat français et du coup j'ai eu
un point de vue de cette guerre et j'ai
trouvé ça trop bien de pouvoir partager
ces moments avec eux ce que nous
souhaitions c'est d'une part
relatée rapportée des histoires arrivées
à des membres de la famille
qui s'insère dans la grande Histoire
donc on a des histoires au moment de la
guerre au moment de la décolonisation
pour l'élève lui-même
cela a permis de d'intensifier le lien
intergénérationnel on a des témoignages
extrêmement touchants très émouvant un
ouvrage destiné alors cercle familial et
amical une dizaine de professeurs
d'histoire-géographie de langue de
philosophie et de lettres accompagnent
les élèves un nouveau livre verra le
jour en 2023 on va passer maintenant à
notre page culture
[Musique]
après le succès de la web série
osef qui a rassemblé plus de 350 000
vues sur Youtube le réalisateur Benjamin
pallier s'est lancé dans la réalisation
d'une nouvelle web série intitulée au
KLM Céline Charlat a assisté à un
tournage d'un des épisodes avec les
élèves du collège Sainte-Thérèse à
Rambouillet regardez silence moteur
ah non
et action l'équipe de tournage du jour
s'est Stanislas Gaspard ou encore romane
tout s'inscrit au cours de pratique
cinématographiques dispensés au collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet ils sont
10 au total et préparent une web série
appelée oklm avec leur professeur le
réalisateur Benjamin pallier originaire
de Rambouillet c'est une série pour les
adolescents qui a été réalisé en gros
pour les adolescents pour parler des
problèmes que peuvent
rencontrer certains adolescents dans
leur scolarité je le temps donc l'autre
rôle principal c'est Enola on est les
deux personnages de la série qui vont
aller dans un kebab raconter leurs
problèmes aux autres
aux assistants aux assistants du kebab
qui tiennent le kebab donc on va leur
parler de nos problèmes et ils vont nous
parler de choses qu'ils ont vécu en lien
avec ces problèmes et ils vont nous
apporter des solutions tenir la perche
vérifier l'enregistreur faire le clap ou
encore le making of sur le tournage tous
les élèves ont un poste qui change au
fil des prises un cours avec un
véritable intérêt pédagogique il permet
aux élèves de découvrir les différents
métiers du cinéma moi ce que je préfère
faire c'est le clap
parce que c'est un peu le truc l'image
du cinéma enfin quand on tourne sur les
dessins animés sur on voit toujours le
clap je préfère faire l'acteur parce que
en fait j'aime beaucoup je suis très à
l'aise à l'oral et j'aime beaucoup faire
ce genre de choses j'aime beaucoup un
carnet un personnage c'est de voir la
progression et l'effort des autres par
rapport à quand on fine à la première
prise et à la dernière prise qu'on prend
et voir le rendu final
quand tu dis waouh pour les films on
voit vraiment que les acteurs mais que
derrière il y a plein de monde pour tout
préparer séparation des parents
harcèlement ou encore stress la web
série aborde des sujets propres à
l'adolescence des thématiques que nous
signe connaissent très bien je fais une
élève en cure de désintoxication pour
jeux vidéo parce que
c'est un peu que je suis addict aussi
dans la vraie vie je trouve que c'est
très important d'en parler parce qu'il y
a il y a plein d'élèves qui sont
concernés et qui peuvent avoir ces
problèmes là c'est ce qui se passe au
collège les discussions qu'on a les
preuves les amis et l'amour sujet
principal au collège ils sont contents
qu'on parle d'eux qu'on parle de toi de
leurs petites aventures du quotidien
qu'on a vécu nous aussi et donc même
pour nous il y a un côté nostalgique et
donc c'est toujours sympa Benoît halmann
voit de Morgane
ce qui m'a énormément plu aussi dans ce
film c'est l'expérience que j'ai pu
vivre au Festival de Cannes puisque
Elvis y a été présenté en première
mondiale avec une acclamation du public
une véritable ovation et beaucoup
d'émotions de la part du réalisateur et
de ses acteurs vous l'avez vu ce film
Mickaël pas du tout mais ça me donne
très envie quand j'entends en parler ça
donne envie de télécharger le film en
tout cas de le
regarderai un coup d'oeil c'est vrai que
c'est un film qui donne envie d'être
regardé on continue de parler au cinéma
avec vous Céline Charles vous nous avez
préparé un petit top des sorties de
cinéma aujourd'hui oui une belle
sélection on commence avec un film très
attendu Black Panther 2 Wakanda Forever
signé Ryan kougler c'est le nouveau
Marvel un film hommage bien sûr à
l'acteur shadowick Bosman décédé en 2020
il incarnait Black Panther alias Chala
le principal protagoniste du premier
opus le film a dû composer avec son
absence la mort du héros est annoncé dès
les premières minutes du film mais pour
autant les antagonistes ne sont jamais
loin il faut un successeur au trône pour
la survie du royaume le choix a été fait
et cette fois-ci place aux femmes
regardez un extrait de la bande-annonce
ils ont perdu leur protecteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui nous sommes
[Musique]
et cette fois-ci ne vous faites pas
avoir il n'y aura pas de scène post
générique à proprement dit comme à
l'accoutumée dans les films Marvel et
non par contre il y aura une séquence
bonus au milieu des crédits voilà c'est
bon à savoir effectivement parce que moi
aussi j'attends les scènes à la fin
voilà comme tout le monde vous êtes
aussi venus Céline avec le nouveau film
de James Grey oui les annoncé comme le
nouveau chef-d'oeuvre de James Grey
Armageddon time avec un casting au petit
oignons anataway Jessica chastin ou
encore bien sûr le grand Anthony Hopkins
c'est un film très personnel pour le
réalisateur qui s'inspire de sa propre
enfance on se retrouve projeté au début
des années 80 dans le Queens quartier
excentré de New York on suit l'histoire
du passage à l'âge adulte d'un jeune
garçon
issu d'une famille juive qui va quitter
le collège public pour intégrer une
école privée tenue par le clan Trump on
suit aussi son amitié fracassante avec
un garçon noir faillite du rêve
américain déterminisme social justice
injustice différence le film aborde
beaucoup de sujets frappant et propre à
la sortie la société de l'époque
regardez je te garantis que tu n'es pas
pris le revoir je comprends pas pourquoi
je crois que tu le sais très bien
mes parents m'ont envoyé au collège de
mon frère ça creux vous qui faites
partie de cette institution vous allez
tous parvenir au sommet jamais on ne
vous aura fait la moindre faveur vous ne
devrez votre ascension car votre mérite
enchanté qu'est-ce qu'il y a
des fois tu réagis comme toi
et vous allez nous parler de deux films
français maintenant Céline Charles c'est
ça lea Drucker et Benoît Poelvoorde sont
à l'affiche du film couleur de
l'incendie de Clovis Cornillac il s'agit
de l'adaptation d'un roman de Pierre
Lemaître c'est l'histoire du destin
d'une femme Madeleine péricourt
héritière d'un empire financier qui se
retrouve face à l'adversité des hommes
et la corruption de la haute société des
années 30 le tout dans un contexte
historique puissant la montée du nazisme
et enfin Mathilde un film franco-belge
dans un registre totalement différent
pétaouchnock une comédie d'aventure
d'Edouard Deluc qui verse dans l'absurde
Ludo et Richard deux amis tout 200
emplois décident de monter une agence de
randonnée équestre pour tourisme pour
touriste en mal de nature seul problème
il n'y connaissent rien du tout les
voilà donc embarqués avec un groupe
assez hétéroclite de 9 participants dans
des aventures rocambolesques le tout au
cœur des montagnes pyrénéennes et bien
moi je pense que j'irai voir Black
Panther 2 ce weekend au cinéma vous avez
peut-être des préférences Miguel
ensemble du coup Mathilde parce que moi
aussi
je vais aller voir Armageddon time c'est
vrai que c'est touchant comme à peu près
tous les films tous les films que vous
avez présenté en tout cas voilà
on poursuit avec notre page culture
musicien
pas du tout je l'ai pas non plus et bien
il s'agit de Raymond Devos il aurait eu
100 ans aujourd'hui il a vécu une
quarantaine d'années dans les Yvelines à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse nous vous
proposons de replonger dans cette dans
son univers pardon
[Musique]
bienvenue à la maison musée Raymond
Devos
[Musique]
c'est dans cette maison que Raymond
Devos a vécu pendant plus de 40 ans 43
ans ils ont acheté cette maison avec sa
femme Simone en 1962 ils sont installés
en 1963 et ils y sont restés jusqu'à la
fin de leur vie donc Raymond Devos est
décédé en 2006 c'était son souhait que
cette maison devienne une fondation et
deviennent un musée et du coup c'est ce
qui s'est passé le musée a ouvert en
2016 donc ici à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
[Musique]
ici on est dans son salon ce qui était
son salon avec quelques éléments
d'origine vous avez le sol et puis vous
avez aussi cette bibliothèque qui a été
fait par lui qui a la forme d'un petit
théâtre de la commedia dell'arte et vous
retrouvez une petite partie de ces
livres et notamment vous retrouvez aussi
son meilleur ami Georges Brassens
[Musique]
ici vous avez quelques jouets du monde
du cirque Raymond Devos a découvert le
cirque quand il était enfant à l'âge de
4-5 ans avec son père et ses frères et
il s'en est jamais remis il aimait tout
dans le cirque et notamment les
disciplines sportives du cirque il a
beaucoup pratiqué ses disciplines et en
fait raymondo c'est un homme assez
sportif malgré son apparence et il a il
a beaucoup pratiqué il était funambule
il marchait sur les mains jusqu'à plus
de 40 ans et il a fait du trampoline
jusqu'à 80 ans donc voilà ça l'a
beaucoup ça lui a beaucoup servi aussi
dans son art sur scène
[Musique]
ici on retrouve derrière le rideau la
loge de Raymond Devos avec toutes ces
affaires reconstituées à l'identique
Raymond Devos c'était très ritualisé
avant de monter sur scène il était très
anxieux il avait un trac immense c'était
très important pour lui d'avoir toutes
ces affaires positionnées comme ça et
notamment dans cette boîte à eux avec
ses nez de clown il avait un petit
rituel c'est qu'il fallait essayer les
cinés avant de choisir lequel était le
bon pour le spectacle du soir alors
qu'ils sont tous identiques
ici on est dans la salle de musique avec
tous les instruments dont Raymond Devos
joué sur scène il était passionné par
les instruments de musique la musique a
toujours fait partie de sa vie depuis
qu'il était enfant grâce à ses parents
lui c'est les trois instruments préférés
c'était la guitare la clarinette et le
piano
et ce qu'il adorait aussi avec les
instruments de musique c'était les
bricoler les tordre un peu dans tous les
sens et donc notamment vous avez cette
clarinette molle qui est une clarinette
fabriquée avec un tuyau d'arrosage en
caoutchouc et puis aussi ce corps de
chasse qui était né d'une boutade de
Georges Brassens qui en parlant de
quelqu'un d'autre disait qu'il avait un
souffle à dérouler un corps de chasse du
coup Raymond Devos s'était dit comment
est-ce qu'on peut transformer ça en
quelque chose d'intéressant et donc il a
pris un pavillon une embouchure il les a
relié par un câble de gazinière pas en
doré
on est ici dans le granit Raymond Devos
c'était sa pièce son espace son ancre en
fait et il venait ici pour créer pour se
faire des journées entières de création
et vous retrouvez en fait tout son bazar
créatif qui était essentiel pour lui
l'avoir sous les yeux c'était très
important pour partie comme il disait
partir du sol du quotidien pour ensuite
s'élever dans l'imaginaire Raymond Devos
en fait c'était un homme passionné qui
émet tout tout l'intéressait tout venait
de nourrir son univers son imaginaire il
aurait voulu avoir plusieurs vies en
fait il estimait que sa vie était trop
courte il aurait voulu tout apprendre et
notamment les instruments de musique
vraiment de vous c'était un musicien
mais c'était aussi un écrivain un
humoriste un circassien il était tout ça
à la fois et on l'oublie parfois parce
que tout ça ça formait en fait la
totalité de son imaginaire
l'automne est bien présent dans les
forêts du département et les champignons
et foisonnent de nombreuses Yvelines
testent ainsi la cueillette de
champignons mais attention celle-ci ne
se fait pas sans risque pour éviter des
intoxications l'association des
naturalistes des Yvelines organisent des
sorties pédagogiques regardées
petit grand rouge violet poilu avec une
odeur de menthe ou encore de noix de
coco les champignons regorgent de
trésors cachés
je vous laisse sentir vous pouvez sentir
sous les lames
odeur particulière par contre faire
attention parce qu'il y a des petites
aussi blancs qui sont terriblement
toxiques et même mortels l'association
des naturalistes des Yvelines organisent
les week-end des sorties pédagogiques en
forêt pour sensibiliser aux champignons
et sur la vingtaine de participants des
novices mais aussi des amateurs éclairés
tout simplement parce que j'aime la
nature j'aime la mycologie j'aime la
botanique et que quand on va en forêt à
cette époxy on a toujours quelque chose
à rapporter depuis que j'ai le temps je
sors vraiment assez souvent en forêt
pratiquement du moins une fois par
semaine minimum quoi et puis le fait de
toujours mettre un vouloir mettre un nom
sur sur chaque espèce qu'on rencontre
sur chaque petite chose puis le fait
aussi que c'est chaque champignon pour
beaucoup de champignons sont liés aussi
aux arbres au terrain etc donc je très
intéressant du coup et puis le fait
aussi de sortir en forêt tout simplement
faire prendre l'air
enchanté
champignons délicieux mais pas courant
l'occasion pour les mycologues de faire
le point sur les champignons comestibles
ou non des grands comestibles il y en a
une quarantaine si vous voulez en tout
on les trouve pas tous ici mais on peut
en trouver une vingtaine sans problème
en forêt Marly on trouve de nombreuses
russules comestibles on trouve des
lépiote les les coulemelles par exemple
à coulemelles on trouve aussi un petit
peu de girolle
on peut trouver du cèpe mais cette année
en Île-de-France c'est pas très riche
parce qu'on a eu un été beaucoup trop
chaud et sec surtout en revanche déjà
une demi-heure ce matin on a trouvé pas
mal d'espèces des quelques amanites des
russules une bonne variété de recul des
lactaires et d'autres et d'autres et
plein d'autres champignons dans notre
département il y aurait 2 à 3000 espèces
de champignons attention donc aux amis
qui sont en fait toxiques ou mort au
moindre doute demandé toujours
l'expertise d'un mycologue ou d'un
pharmacien
[Musique]
Michael midoro Céline Charles est-ce que
ça vous a donné envie de partir à la
cueillette des champignons évidemment
moi je suis un très très grand fan de
champignons donc oui pourquoi pas vous
êtes déjà parti
effectivement donc ce reportage m'a
intéressé
moi aussi une adepte de champignons par
contre je m'aventure jamais en forêt
j'ai toujours peur qu'il soit toxique je
demande me tromper donc sur portage mais
un peu aider donc vous les cueillez mais
vous les mangez pas je les cueille pas
du tout je vais les acheter directement
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant je vous
propose qu'on se quitte avec la météo de
demain
demain matin dans les Yvelines le
brouillard sera bien présent sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures comptées 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles 7 degrés à
Houdan et 6 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le brouillard devrait se
dissiper pour laisser place à de belles
éclaircies au niveau des températures il
fera 11 à 14 degrés en moyenne et demain
nous fêterons les saintes Leon c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi jusqu'au bout avec nous je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]